hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that asks questions on you know
the Batman vs Superman trailer the flash
and arrow episodes this week there's a
lot of stuff to talk to so I tried to
compress this just so I could do as much
as possible so just start with a Batman
vs Superman trailer I know it's you know
technically it's Batman V Superman I'm
not a huge fan of the fact that they
went with the V instead of the outright
vs but I think once we get closer to the
actual movie they'll explain the logic
behind that I think it'll be part of the
story of the film because they will be
coming together in Justice League for
the most part this will be Batman and
Superman at each other's throats
speaking of which the first big question
the Alfred voiceover where he talked he
talks about fear and feeling of
powerlessness turning good men cruel
he's actually talking about all of the
main characters not just Lex Luthor and
Superman he's talking about Batman even
the regular people like the Senators
somatically it's like the John F Kennedy
speech the famous speech the only thing
we have to fear is fear itself as you
would guess all of the heroes will be
able to overcome their fear by the end
of the film Lex Luthor will not that's
why he's the villain he will succumb to
becoming a cruel person even though
Batman looks like he's really ready to
make Superman bleed in this so next big
question how does Batman beat Superman
in this film if Superman is a god or the
closest you can get to being a god we
know that in this universe Superman does
kill which is actually a departure from
previous films him killing zawas a
really big deal this scene actually here
takes place where that happened that's
Batman really tiny on screen you can
barely see him the ways x ladder
explained the logic of killings odd is
that Superman felt like he had no other
choice he obviously he has a choice
whether or not to kill Batman so he is
not going to kill Batman Batman however
does not make that distinction he is
totally willing to kill Superman add to
that he has unlimited money and he's
every bit as cunning as genius Lex
Luthor he will find a weakness in
Superman to exploit just like Lex Luthor
well it might not be the same weakness
but he will find something there are
things that like Superman can't fight
like internet piracy how does Superman
fight internet piracy how does Superman
stop a trailer from being leaked solve
that problem you can't heat vision
everyone's computers in the world next
big question that plane looks like it's
shooting bullets at people a lot of
people are thinking that this is the
batplane
mean and Batman is trying to kill these
people here I don't think that's the
case that's not confirmed batwing and we
don't know that Batman is flying it it
could be someone else co-opting Batman's
technology or it could be some other
criminal element in the film Lex
Luthor's probably not going to be the
only bone we see speaking of villains
that big voiceover you know do you bleed
a lot of people are wondering if that's
maybe like another person in the film
like another villain character and not
Batman I still think that it's Batman
affecting his voice with technology I
noticed a few people commenting that
Kevin Smith said something about about
them affecting Batman's voice with
technology as opposed to him doing it
himself like doing the christian bale
batman voice technique I can't confirm
that but I do think that that's Batman
saying that line there's no way that
they would tease us with like a Batman
vs Superman punch out without actually
doing it on screen that would be the
biggest middle finger to everyone
watching this trailer yes they will
settle their differences by the end of
the trailer but not before they punch it
out just like a little bit that doesn't
even address what wonder woman's role is
going to be in this film if she's every
bit as strong as Superman what is she
gonna be doing most of the time in her
comics her MO is that she is a diplomat
so I think she's gonna be something of
an intermediary like I said before
though most of this film is going to be
Batman and Superman I think you know
Wonder Woman will be in there but she
won't have his bigger role as those two
characters next big question Neil
deGrasse Tyson I saw a lot of people
wondering if he's going to be tied to
the cyborg character because cyborg had
like a like a scientist data worked at
STAR Labs I don't think that's the case
I think that Neil deGrasse Tyson in the
movie will be playing Neil deGrasse
Tyson because a lot of sci-fi superhero
films want to tie themselves to the real
world seem more realistic they'll invoke
real-life characters in the film's it'd
be like Stanley playing Stanley in a
Marvel film Neil deGrasse Tyson is just
like the rock star of the science world
so he's one of the more fun people to
bring into a film just because he's
really good on camera if you've never
watched his show cosmos it's a lot of
fun you should check it out next big
thing the IMX screening so what's
happening is is because of the leak Zack
Snyder added a couple of shots to the
imax screening so if you're going to a
theater to see the trailer on Monday
you'll see more footage than we saw in
this official trailer here I don't think
we'll see Lex Luthor of Wonder Woman or
Aquaman or those characters I think the
extra scenes they added will just add
some
our context for what's going on in the
film if you remember Avengers age of
Ultron they waited till the third
trailer to put vision in so moving into
flash territory I know a lot of you guys
are asking about like the staggered
episodes because it next week is episode
19 of the flash but it's episode 20 of
arrow so here's what's going on the
timeline of both shows is meant to sync
up so when episode 19 of the flash is
happening episode 19 of arrow is
happening it's a little messed up that
the episodes are out of sync but the way
they wrote the episodes they totally
work it's not going to completely mess
up the story of each episode they design
it that way on purpose like when they do
crossover episodes they try to make it
so that it works on its own even if you
missed like that that week's episode of
the other show so if you see episode 20
of arrow but you miss episode 20 of the
flash it's not going to completely mess
stuff up I think one of the best moments
that you guys commented on on arrow this
week is that Oliver said why don't we
just get Barry to solve this problem
that's been the question ever since the
season started like how come Oliver just
doesn't call the flash to come and fix
his problems especially the mid-season
finale Felicity's answer to that is that
Barry is just like so effed up in the
head that he can barely handle getting
up in the morning so regardless of what
you think of Felicity's excuse they did
address it and I think they'll continue
to do that to say like hey why don't we
just call this person and then some
other character will say well we can't
because XYZ you also have to consider
that Oliver is getting ready to or seems
like he's getting ready to join the
League of Assassins I don't think that
we won't address that on the flash
someone will say something about that
makes big question WTF is going on with
Eddie and iris and is that going to
inform Eddie maybe turning bad or doing
something crazy we have a little more
context for Eddie killing these two cops
in the trailer no I don't think that has
anything to do with Grodd I think that's
the shapeshifter this character is every
man from the comics that that's who this
is so whenever we see Barry Allen
finding himself in the trailer that's
that's also from that episode probably
it's just the shapeshifter taking on
properties of other people that he
touches the fun part is is that the
everyman project is something that Lex
Luthor did in the DC Universe so it's
like you know like a subtle title Lex
Luthor but I don't think they'll ever be
able to mention Lex Corp on the flash
the next couple of episodes will give
you a better idea of how Eddie's
relationship with team flash is going to
change going into the season 4
Ali I do you know he is a good character
but i think that events will conspire to
make him do something that he's not
proud of a bard on the reverse-flash
will still be the big villain this
season like they're not going to change
that there won't be any dramatic left
turns it's all building up to this big
team up moment firestorm Rach Amell in
the flash vs the reverse-flash what I do
think is going to happen is is the
reverse-flash will start targeting iris
and then that will put Eddie and bearing
this really weird situation moving into
our territory so I know everyone's
asking about the League of Assassins
Oliver joining up baby becoming the next
ratio goal in Thea getting in the
Lazarus Pit just to start with the first
thing Oliver joining the League of
Assassins I don't think he's going to
immediately become Rochelle cool he'll
just he'll join the league so that Thea
can use the Lazarus Pit I think the next
couple of episodes after that you know
before the finale will deal with the
idea of succession you know I don't
think that this is just gonna sit idly
by I think that you will try to help
team arrow in some way next big question
who is that mystery woman that we keep
seeing in all the trailers the woman
that looks like she is related tennis or
a ratio cool she could be mrs. mother
what I don't think is that she is a
comic book character that we haven't
heard about yet like Lady Shiva
typically characters like that that are
really big they announced those whenever
they cashed them so I do think she is a
character that flows from the comic
books but but I don't think she's like a
comic book superhero or super villain
next big question what's going on with
the spin-off and a lot of you are asking
so what's happened is is that they've
finished filming both seasons of the
arrow and flash and there was a scene
with pictures of spin-off characters on
a rooftop we don't know if the scene is
going to be part of either episodes of
the finale what I think is going to
happen is is it's gonna be like that
fight club trailer where it's not it's
not part of an episode it's just like a
fun promo moment I think what'll happen
is is that they'll air the finale zabo
shows and then they'll air a teaser for
the spin-off show because they haven't
even finished filming the spin-off yet
they haven't even finished casting it
yet they have filmed footage with those
characters with some of the spin-off
characters so what they're doing is is
they're probably just teeing up what's
going to be happening in the spin-off
it's totally possible if they are
filming a trailer for that that they
could wait till comic-con to air it but
I think that they would want to air that
after like the finale of the flash and
arrow just to maximize viewership rain
and all the spin-off stuff it is still
just a lot of speculation we still don't
know how
lots is coming back we still don't know
who some of those other mystery
characters are we still don't know who
the villain is but thank you so much
everyone for so many questions he's
always a ton of fun to do so next week
new episodes of air on the flash you
know if there's a neat like really crazy
new footage in the imax Batman vs
Superman trailer I'll let you guys all
do new video for it I'm also going to be
seeing avengers age of ultron on tuesday
night so i'm going to do like a
non-spoilery review of that so be sure
to subscribe to get that that's going to
be a lot of fun I'm still trying to get
through the rest of my daredevil videos
I've seen the whole season I just I
haven't had time to make videos for all
the episodes yet tomorrow will be new
game of throat so i'll be doing you know
bonus video episode video for that just
like normal with the new round of the
giveaway it's been a really awesome week
lots of Star Wars stuff happening lots
of Marvel lots of DC stuff so while you
guys wait for me to finish all those
other videos you can click here to watch
the Batman V Superman trailer like 10 15
more times and you can click here to
watch the Star Wars trailer again thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you